now on the conservative side as you know
a lot of flying theories going about
anomalies uh episodic fraud i mean look
at this dead guy who voted over here
look at that guy was stuffing ballots
over there
but of course the courts in these
situations
use the principle that can be called the
but for principle but for the fraud
would the election have come out
differently and that's a pretty high bar
you have to show a magnitude of fraud
and that was i never felt was really
done never shown never proven and so
again i thought let's move on this is
something that we might never know so it
wasn't until i sat down with the the two
principles of the organization called
true the vote that i realized that they
had sort of approached the election like
a cold case like cold case files and
they figured out you know there actually
is a way to go back and and track the
movements of these so-called mules and
there is a way also to look uh through
surveillance video and in a sense take
us back to the days before and during
the 2020 election to actually see what
happened with your own two eyes
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an author podcast host and creator of
the new film 2000 mules which is out
right now dinesh d'souza welcome back to
the reuben report
dave it's a real pleasure thanks for
having me back i'm looking forward to it
it's been a couple years since we've
chatted on camera my friend but i feel
that we have to give a warning right up
top here there is a good chance that my
channel will be blown up on youtube
because of this
but
i did create locals you launched 2 000
mules on locals which i obviously want
to get into and i'm honored that you did
that and anything that we cannot put on
youtube for this interview we will put
up well i'll just say we'll put it up on
both our channels fair enough
i mean dave what a surreal time we live
in i i don't think you and i would have
predicted a decade ago that we would
find that these basic liberties which
are supposed to be outside the bounds of
politics free speech rights for example
would somehow be abridged in this way
and we'd have to watch what we say and
figure out should i put this up i have
exactly the same issue with my daily
podcast um and with this movie you know
i couldn't put the trailer up on youtube
i couldn't buy ads on facebook so i had
to develop an entirely different
business plan for releasing this movie
as compared to any of my earlier ones
so let's get into that business plan in
just a moment but first let's let's
focus on the movie itself i was at the
i suppose it was the pre-premiere of the
movie which was at mar-a-lago and it was
sort of a of a who's who of uh let's say
right-wing media or whatever you want to
call all of us at this point uh and i
got to see the movie i thought it was
excellent many people on my book tour
one of the questions that i got more
than anything else over the last couple
weeks was what did you think of the
movie and i recommended that everyone
see it make some judgments for
themselves what was the initial starting
point of when you did you want to
immediately ask questions like the night
of the election or was it a couple weeks
later what was sort of the genesis of
the whole idea well like a lot of people
i i noticed the anomalies of 2020 and
they struck me as really strange but
once the curtain well once biden was
inaugurated and then of course a curtain
of censorship descends on this topic i
thought man you know we probably will
never find out what really happened in
the 2020 election with each passing day
the event becomes more remote and and i
was dissatisfied with the rhetoric a
little bit on both sides now you know
start with the left the most secure
election in history and i thought to
myself even before i started anything
with 2 000 mules well how could you
possibly know that and they'd be like
well dinesh where's your proof of fraud
and i'm like well let's say i had none i
have no proof does it make it the most
secure election of all time i mean right
these are still separate things yeah you
haven't done an actual comparison of the
amount of fraud in the last seven
elections for example to show me that it
was the least in 2020 and yet that
became the mantra now on the
conservative side as you know a lot of
flying theories going about
anomalies uh episodic fraud i mean look
at this dead guy who voted over here
look at that guy was stuffing ballots
over there but of course the courts in
these situations
use the principle that can be called the
but for principle but for the fraud
would the election have come out
differently and that's a pretty high bar
you have to show a magnitude of fraud
and that was i never felt was really
done never shown never proven and so
again i thought let's move on this is
something that we might never know so it
wasn't until i sat down with the the two
principles of the organization called
true the vote that i realized that they
had sort of approached the election like
a cold case like coal case files and
they figured out you know there actually
is a way to go back and and track the
movements of these so-called mules and
there is a way also to look uh through
surveillance video and in a sense take
us back to the days before and during
the 2020 election to actually see what
happened with your own two eyes
okay so before we get into some of the
specifics of how they use geotagging and
how they were actually tracking these
mules and i want you to actually define
what a mule is what you do in the movie
obviously how do you as a filmmaker
because you've obviously made a bunch of
documentaries before how do you make
sure that your own personal
opinions don't override the truth
because to me that's got to be the
hardest part i think there are moments
in the movie where you sort of address
that a little bit but to remove all of
your bias for all of us is almost
completely impossible
it is impossible and i would argue that
in terms of attaining that kind of pure
objectivity that's never going to happen
i mean that doesn't occur uh at all but
what you can do is try to have that sort
of
empathetic ability and it's a debating
ability by the way to always see the
strength of the counter-argument of the
other guy's point of view and import
that into the film also one of my
techniques here was
i recognize that among the kind of salem
podcast hosts i'm thinking of people
like eric mataxis and larry elder there
were a mix of views about the election
some of them it was stolen for sure some
of them nah i haven't seen any proof of
it and i had the idea of importing them
into the movie uh having their initial
thoughts then showing them the evidence
and literally spontaneously filming
their reaction and then asking them for
their assessments i thought in this way
it goes beyond just sort of dinesh's
singular interpretation and it becomes a
conversation about the issue in which
it's possible that somebody watching the
movie would go you know i see stronger
ground in what larry elder is saying
than anything dinesh might have said so
by by doing it that way it does what a
good movie does which is it lays out a
narrative with a range of positions and
a range of potential possible
interpretations it was interesting so
you use this round table of the salem
host so it's it's you and dennis prager
and larry elder and eric mataxis and
charlie kirk am i forgetting anyone oh
and seb gorka and gordon
and you guys sort of spur you know you
guys come and go throughout the movie
discussing what's going on and it's
interesting because dennis i think comes
off as the most skeptical at the
beginning he kind of comes around a
little bit more but everyone's asking
questions throughout and obviously you
didn't cut the questions so uh
there's some credit there i mean in some
ways that's the best part where dennis
will say for example hey listen you know
you have a mule you're showing this guy
stuffing ballots what if you run up to
him right now and grab his ballots and
look at them what would you see on the
ballot i mean what's cool about it to me
is i thought to myself those are the
kinds of questions that people in the
audience are going to be asking so by
putting them right in the movie the
movie doesn't have to come back and
answer those questions because they are
anticipated and addressed and at least
discussed in the film itself okay so for
the people that have not seen it yet
without blowing anything major can you
at least can you give the kind of
elevator pitch on the the methodology
that you guys were looking at related to
people's smartphones and where they were
going and just the the basic idea of
what 2000 mules is
sure the the film drawing on the work of
this group called true the vote a kind
of election intelligence group if you
will
uses two independent modes of
investigation or two two modes of
argument the first one is cell phone geo
tracking
and that arises out of the simple point
that we're at a stage of technology now
and perhaps also a stage where we have
relinquished our privacy to a point now
where our movements can be tracked uh
they're tracked because of not because
of cell phone towers that are pinging
it's because of apps inside our phone
that allow so-called aggregators to
collect this data and by the way it's
sold on the open market commercial
companies can buy it it's also very
valuable to law enforcement intelligence
agencies but essentially if i was being
geotracked right now uh you could tell
for sure i woke up in my bedroom in my
house i then went to a coffee shop then
i went to the studio to record my
podcast and i had lunch with a friend at
this restaurant then i came home and all
of that is shown
not by a single snapshot of my phone but
by what's called a pattern of life
you're showing the movement of my cell
phone now obviously if i gave myself one
to my wife debbie it would show her
movements but that the cell phone is
making these movements and going to
these locations is really not open to
doubt and so what true the vote did is
they used the cell phone geo-tracking
used in many other areas they're kind of
genius idea was let's apply that to
ballot trafficking and what we're
looking for are these mules now what's a
mule
basically a paid operative who is handed
ballots
and asked to drop them off to deliver
them to uh mail and drop boxes and uh
and we've been able to identify based on
a criterion actually a very high
criterion mules going to ten or more
drop boxes
some two thousand mules and that's where
the title of the movie comes from if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell